allein kannst du mich hören die frage
was kannst du uns berichten der blick
von oben gestellt sich von dort die lage
jetzt der zeit da also die straße ist
nach wie vor gesperrt an der torstraße
die polizei ruhig sagte gemacht dass die
veranstaltung aufgelöst ist wegen nicht
einhaltung der hygienevorschriften
demonstranten sitzen auf der
friedrichstraße und noch hin
diese und warten die nicht frei jetzt
gerade vor zwei minuten haben es zu den
ersten rangeleien und die stimmung ist
halt eben gereizt und die leute sitzen
auf der friedrichstraße umgeben diesel
nichts weiter in der chausseestraße 4
500 meter vor mir steht schon ein
wasserwerfer in bereitschaft ja wir
sehen dort staut es sich die polizei
plant ja eigentlich das ganze aufzulösen
geht aber wohl sehr mit bedacht derzeit
vor
hast du das gefühl dass sich dort jetzt
immer mehr menschen drängen oder sieht
es von oben zumindest ein bisschen so
aus als würde sich das langsam wieder
ein bisschen verteilen also die leute
werden nicht mehr reinlassen
ich rede die straße und das beliebte und
sogar reportern dass die leute nicht
mehr weiter gelassen werden
deswegen schaut sich das hier es gibt
aber nicht mehr nur wie bekommt man
diese leute wird wenn sie nicht
freiwillig gehen dann sagt im prinzip
nur härtere einsatzmittel das muss der
polizeiführer entscheiden wahrscheinlich
wird sehr friedlich die eskalation und
mit gesprächen versucht letztendlich der
linie gehen weil ich vielleicht
übermacht wird oder die wasserwerfer
werden eingesetzt
sein kollege fabian matzerath von oben
mit eindrucksvollen bildern
zehntausende menschen sind derzeit in
berlin auf der straße um gegen die
korona regeln zu demonstrieren